Let's get started.
Settle down. The weekend has not
quite started.
Let's look at what happened on
Wednesday. There are the scores.
Class average about 67, standard
deviation about 17,
so that means it is a bell curve
sitting right on the 50.
A lot of people improved.
There were a lot of rags to riches
stories, but there are still a fair
number of people down here.
And so my suggestion to you is that
if you are down here
and you want to --
Too much talking,
people. If you want to start your
weekend soon, I will help you by
inviting you to leave.
You don't have to stay here if you
don't want to,
but if you do choose to stay,
please sit in silence. This is 3.
91. If you are down here, get in
and see us. Please talk to your
recitation instructor,
come on in and see me, and we will
talk about strategies for studying,
strategies for success. I want you
to pass this class,
but just doing the same thing over --
This is, I think,
Einstein's definition of insanity,
doing the same thing over and over
again expecting a different outcome.
If what you have been doing up to
now is not working,
let's try something else.
And we can help you. The model
solutions are up and,
if there are changes that need to be
made, please get in to see me.
Why don't we agree not to do it
until Monday.
I would like you to first talk to
your recitation instructor and make
sure that there is something worth
exploring. The final exam is on the
15th of December.
The final exam is going to
essentially represent the equivalent
of a double monthly test.
You will have three hours.
But I give about double the amount
of work, so it should give you
enough time to finish.
But the final exam will consist of
a mix of what is covered since Test
3. It is like a Test 4 monthly.
And also some material going all the
way back to the beginning of the
semester. It is both cumulative and
focused, so it has breadth and depth.
And it is really good to pass the
final. If people pass the final,
it tilts things in favor of passing
the class. If you crash and burn on
the final, it raises a lot of
questions as to whether you have
been working all along,
you gave up around Veteran's Day and
so on. I urge you to keep at it.
And don't leave everything to the
last minute. If you take a look at
your final exam schedule,
this is the third day of the final
exam period. Some of you may have
exams Monday and Tuesday.
If you think you are going to cram
it all in on Tuesday night,
it is not going to work. You are
going to be very tired by the middle
of that week. You need to have a
plan. You have to work
incrementally so that things sink in.
You cannot just do high-speed
Fick's second law and expect it is
all just going to go zooming in.
It won't. It will look like first
law. It will go in this side and
out the other side.
Keep at it. Well, let's get on
with the lesson.
Today is going to be a chance to
apply the organic chemistry that we
learned on Monday.
I said we learned enough organic
chemistry to set the stage for
polymers, so today we are going to
talk about polymers.
Monday we will come back and finish
up polymers, and then that will lead
us into biochemistry.
This is all part of applied organic
chemistry. To date,
what are the types of solids that we
have seen in 3.
91? We saw solids that are
consisting of single atoms stacked.
Then we saw compounds stacked.
Last day we started looking at
chains. And we have even seen
networks, some of them amorphous,
some of them crystalline. Today
what we are going to look at is a
new form of solid where the building
block is a long chain, long
in quotation marks.
And this is a polymer.
Polymers are pervasive in our
society. We see them in everything
from your CDs,
the CD cases. You see them in trash
bags. You see them in clothing,
microfibers. Some of these new
fibers have an incredible mix of
properties in terms of comfort and
security. Auto parts.
All over the map. And,
when it comes to soft matter,
we, as human beings are solid state
devices.
Mother Nature is a polymer chemist.
It is all macromolecular chemistry.
If we want to introduce polymers
today, let's have an operating
definition. A polymer is a long
chain molecule with a repeating
chemical structure.
And let me give you an example.
I will give you one that builds on
something we saw the other day.
We have seen ethylene or ethene.
This is C2H4, and it has the
chemical structure.
What we can do is turn this into a
long chain molecule with a repeating
chemical structure in the following
manner. We can react it with
something that will catalyze the
destruction of this double bond.
And once this double bond is broken
we can flip it over to the other
side of the carbon giving us the
opportunity to continue to link.
This is done with a radical,
so we can denote the radical R.
And I am going to put this,
remember, the unpaired electron.
This is a radical with its unpaired
electron which we term an initiator.
And so this initiator, when it
meets something with a double bond,
reacts. The double bond is
something that could be turned into
two single bonds. Let's
go to maximize bonds.
This one has no bond,
broken. This one has a double bond.
We could react the two and result
in the following,
and now this goes over to here.
Now the initiator has attacked this
double bond, built the bridge,
and now the radical is at the end
here.
Well, ethylene is a gas.
If this is sitting in a reactor,
gas molecules are colliding with
this, so now we can attack another
ethylene and so on.
You get the picture.
Eventually this thing is thousands
and thousands of atoms long.
Let's do one more.
And now we will have the bond here,
one, two, three, four, like so.
And so now you see a repeat unit.
Here is a repeat unit. And this
repeat unit can go n times where n
is very, very large.
N can be on the order of ten
thousand or so giving us molecules
that have atomic masses of a million
grams per mole.
These are huge.
We call this n. I am using n now
in a new way.
N is called the polymerization index
and it represents the number of
repeats of the mer unit.
The mer is the repeat unit.
And what is the length of this
thing? Let's get a sense of this.
Suppose we had something that was,
say, ten thousand units long. Let's
say n is ten thousand,
that might give me something on the
order of about a million
grams per mole.
Let me do the calculation a
different way.
Suppose I had something that had an
atomic mass of a hundred thousand
grams per mole.
This is the atomic mass of the
polymer. And divide that by the
atomic mass of ethylene.
Ethylene is 28 grams per mole.
This is the mass of C2H4 and this
is the mass of the polyethylene,
one molecule.
That would give us then a
polymerization index of 3,
71, about 3,600. And, if we
estimate a carbon-carbon bond
distance, about one and a half
angstroms for carbon-carbon bond
distance, that gives us something
that is on the order of about a half
a micron in length for one molecule.
And to give you a sense of what that
really means, I want to show you a
demo here. What I have is a pull
chain that you use downstairs in
grandma's house to turn on the
lights. This is a whole bunch of
these brass balls that are held
together by metal.
Let's have each of these represent
carbon. And this one is about three
thousand units long, about 40 feet.
There are about three thousand of
these units here.
Let's get a sense of how big this
is.
This is one molecule.
Imagine what happens when this,
in the melt state, is flowing. What
happens when the melt decreases in
temperature and this attempts to
solidify? What are the chances that
this is going to come out in one of
the 14 Bravais lattices?
It is vanishingly small.
I feel like I just came back from
New Orleans.
I didn't even have to lift my shirt.
Look at all this stuff I have.
This is terrific.
That is one molecule.
And, if we imagine what happens,
let's say that it is pretty clear
that, let's call this macromolecule,
solid macromolecules favor being
amorphous.
Favor the amorphous state.
This is a notion of pure
crystallization.
And we can imagine,
for example, all of the rules that
we learned for the inorganic glasses,
the silicates apply to organic
glasses. Let's look at,
say, volume versus temperature for
something like polyethylene.
I am just going to call this PE,
polyethylene for short.
We can imagine we are up here in the
melt state, we cool down,
we go through a normal melting point
and then we reach a solidification
at some glass transition temperature.
Let's say this is at a slow cooling
rate, so this is Tg slow.
And maybe on another occasion we
cool at a fast rate,
and so we will have a different
glass transition temperature and it
will be higher.
And let's say this over here is room
temperature. What do I find?
I have two different volumes.
You have seen this before. If I
have for constant mass equal masses.
The one with the higher volume has
the lower density.
This should be low-density.
Let me just put the fast cooling
rate. Fast cool.
This is slow cool.
This will be low-density
polyethylene formed here and this
will be high-density polyethylene
simply by the different rates of
cooling. Constant mass means then
that you have density is mass over
volume, so the one with the higher
volume gives us the lower mass.
We can see how by different
processing we have the ability to
change between high-density and
low-density polyethylene as a
function of the cooling rate.
Now, other things can happen.
If we go at a low rate of cooling,
we can get even down here at very,
very low cooling rates.
We might even get some degree of
crystallization.
Could we switch over to the
document camera feed,
please? Let's see what happens when
this thing attempts to crystallize.
Here we are. What can happen is if
we cool at a slow enough rate,
this cannot form a single crystal
but what it can do is fold back on
itself and, thereby,
put these atoms into a regular
arrangement.
This is now forming a zone of
crystallinity.
And why is it doing this?
It is doing this to maximize Van
der Waals bonding here.
The tighter it packs, the greater
the intensity of bond formation.
We see this happening in the
formation of such zones
of crystallinity.
And when this happens we have a
change in properties.
Let's consider low-density
polyethylene. Well,
we know that this thing is going to
be mechanically flexible.
It is going to be flexible because
what are the only bonds operative
here? They are just weak Van der
Waals bonds, mechanically flexible.
It is high band-gap material and it
is amorphous.
There are no grains,
there are no grain boundaries so it
is transparent because of the high
band-gap and it is clear.
We can see through it because there
are no internal surfaces.
That is low-density polyethylene.
High-density polyethylene, well, it
has some zones of this.
The high-density polyethylene has
these near crystalline zones,
and then it is broadly amorphous.
The difference here is small.
The density here is about 0.92
grams per centimeter cubed,
and this is about 0.96 grams per
centimeter cubed.
There is a little bit of tighter
packing here. But what happens when
we get into these zones of
regularity, because there is a
higher atom density,
this turns out to have a higher
reactivity with light.
Therefore, I am using n here not to
mean index of polymerization.
This is index of refraction.
The index of refraction in the near
crystalline zones is not equal to
the index of refraction in the
amorphous zones.
Now we have zones that are near
crystalline in zones that are
amorphous. And so we have the
effect of internal interface.
And, as a result, the high-density
polyethylene is opaque.
These zones here add rigidity.
There is a stiffness here. This
one is rigid. What do we have?
We have low-density polyethylene.
This is what you see in use in food
wrap. Whereas,
this is what you see in the milk
jugs, the milk jugs that are
somewhat hardened and
do not admit light.
They are both the same material,
but what has happened is just a
slight change in the strength of the
material through a change in
processing, a change in cooling rate.
Let's look at how we can take this
idea of tailoring properties and
extend it more broadly and maybe put
it on a firmer footing.
Let's look at the various items in
our toolbox. We want to tailor the
properties. The first thing we can
do is control composition.
Control of composition - that is
purity. We can start with pure
polymers and polymers that are made
of combinations of different
polymers. Let's start
with the pure polymer.
The pure polymer,
because it comes from a different
heritage, have their own terminology.
Pure polymers or polymers
consisting of a single mer are
called homopolymers.
They consist of a single mer,
one mer type, and it is repeated.
For example, polyethylene.
Ethylene is the repeat unit.
And that is all you see.
Polyethylene from end to end.
Then if we want to mix different
mers, we get what is to a polymer
what we would call an alloy in a
metal system. And this is called a
copolymer. It has more than one
type. Greater than one mer type.
And so, for example, we could make
a copolymer of,
say, polyethylene with,
say, polyvinylchloride.
Polyethylene and polyvinylchloride.
And, this notation, this lower case
c with the hyphens on either side
indicate that we are talking about a
copolymer of these two units.
You know what the parent unit is of
ethylene, I have shown you that.
And we saw last day that if we took
ethylene, dropped a hydrogen,
this became the vinyl radical.
And then, if we put a chlorine here,
this is vinyl chloride. It has a
double bond here.
We can use the same polymerization
technique, propagate this by
converting it to a single bond.
And now, instead of vinyl chloride,
we will have the polymer
polyvinylchloride.
And, if we had both vinyl chloride
in the reactor and ethylene in the
reactor, we would be grabbing
molecules of both types
and attaching them.
So, as you move down the chain,
you might have ethylene unit, vinyl
chloride unit,
ethylene unit and so on.
And, if we could go to the computer
feed, I can show some examples of
different ways in which we can put
these on the chain.
The first one, this is taken right
from your reading,
is called the random copolymer where
A and B represent different mer
units. A could be ethylene and B
could be vinyl chloride.
And here they are just random.
You get some unit of vinyl chloride
and then several units and so on.
And some people want this for
particular mechanical properties,
so let's document these different
types. If we have random
arrangement of the mer groups,
random arrangement of mer types,
we have what is called the random
copolymer. Let's just
use this same example.
This could be polyethylene lower
case r-PVC. That tells you it is a
random copolymer.
The next one shows what they are
calling a regular copolymer where
you have alternating.
It is strict alternating
arrangement of mer-type.
It moves from one to the other in
alternating sequence.
And this is known as the
alternating copolymer
to distinguish it.
You cannot call it regular because
"r" is already taken for the random
copolymer. The third one is shown
up here where we take and cluster
the different mer types.
Instead of having alternating one
to the other, we take a run of one
type of mer and then a run of
another type of mer.
This is a clustered arrangement of
mer types into what we call these
clusters, are called blocks of the
same type of mer.
And such a material is called a
block copolymer,
which is shown up here where you see
there are four units of A and then
four units of B and then two units
of A, four units of B.
This is a little bit unrealistic.
Typically, commercial block
copolymers are usually diblocks or
triblocks. If it were a diblock of
polyethylene, it would be one run of
polyethylene and one run of
polyvinylchloride and that is it.
You don't do this sort of thing but
the artist got carried away and
somebody didn't proofread.
And the last thing you can do is
the one on the bottom which is
called the graft.
The graft is sort of a type of
block copolymer where what you have
is graft of one mer type in the form
of a side chain onto another mer
type for the backbone.
You cluster them but you cluster
them very deliberately in this
manner, and that is shown in the
bottom one. The backbone is all As
and the side chain is all Bs.
And here is one. Some of you are
going to be doing some traveling so
I have put up a very common one.
This is ABS,
acrylonitrile-butadiene-styrene.
You have seen butadiene. We say
that last day,
styrene. What this is,
the backbone is all butadiene,
and then the side chains are
alternately acrylonitrile and
styrene. And this is what is used
for hard sided luggage and also this.
All these old telephones are made
of this graft copolymer.
And, by playing with the nature of
these side chains,
we can obviously make this so that
it is somewhat flexible,
or we could make it so that it is
rather rigid. Again,
examples of architecture at the
local level dictating properties.
We have these examples of how we
can tailor the properties.
The second thing is the
configurations of the side groups.
Side group configuration.
These are all options that we have.
And we exercise them in the
synthesis, by playing with the
synthesis conditions and also the
catalysts that are present.
And that is shown here. There are
basically three ways you can put the
side groups on.
The upper one shows the methyl
group randomly going.
Sometimes it is above,
sometimes it is below, and there
seems to be no pattern.
This whole notion of side group
configuration is referred to as
tacticity. It means the placement
of the side groups.
There are only three choices here.
Either you put them all on the same
side of the chain,
that is the bottom one,
isotactic, or you put them on
alternate. One sits on one side of
the chain then it is on the other
side of the chain.
You alternate back and forth with
regularity. That is syndiotactic.
And then the third case is, come
what may, there is no seeming plan,
and that is the atactic.
Those are the three types that you
need to be aware of,
isotactic, syndiotactic and atactic.
And you can figure those out. Iso
obviously means they are all on the
same side of the chain.
Atactic is as amoral, apolitical,
so this is random. And then by
elimination this must
be alternating.
And I think on the next one I did a
little doodling for you.
Just to bring home what is going on,
the first one at the top is atactic
polypropylene.
So you see there is propylene.
And what has happened is this
double bond has been broken and now
it can propagate.
And this methyl group in some cases
is above and in some cases below the
chain. Here is polystyrene.
This is vinyl benzene or
phenylethene or styrene.
And this double bond is broken and
you have these phenyl groups hanging
off the side. And this is just
vinyl chloride which we saw over
here. Again, seeing the synthesis.
Then the last thing we can look at
is backbone architecture or chain
architecture. Chain here referring
to the main chain.
And this falls under the general
term of conformality.
And we are going to revisit this
when we talk about proteins.
It is very important in biological
systems. And it is a direct result
of this, which I showed you last day,
that this bond is free to rotate.
And, if it rotates in certain ways
so that all the side groups line up
perfectly, you end up with this
so-called eclipsed version.
If you look at the chain on the very
end you would see one dot that
represents the backbone.
Actually, it is zigzagging.
You would see the edge of the
zigzag. And then all of the pendant
groups will be lined up in front of
one another and you would see
nothing except the very first one.
That is the eclipse and that is the
most regular, straight line.
And this is staggered where it
rotates where it wishes.
And I showed you this one where
this is hardly something with the
polymerization index of 3600.
But it starts giving you the sense
of some are more nearly straight and
some are very heavily coiled.
Both of these are still called
straight chains,
but there are some things that we
can look at. First we have the
linear one, the linear chain
molecule. And so that is one.
Furthermore, if you look here,
there is some fine structure.
You may even see that at some point
along here there is even some
attempt at crystallization.
But, even so, the system moves in
one direction from one end to
another. The alternative is
branched chain.
It is a different type of
architecture. In that case,
you actually have something that -
This is not graft.
This is actually the main component
of the backbone continuing to grow
but growing in a plurality of paths.
You can imagine that one of these
is going to pack much better than
the other. One is going to have a
greater chance of forming such zones
of crystallinity.
Clearly, it is going to be the
linear chain. These branches stick
out and they prevent tight packing.
The branched chain is harder to
crystallize.
And, when it forms its amorphous
structures, it has more free volume.
And also you can think about the
glass transition temperature,
Tg, how is that going to work and so
on. By looking at the branching you
end up with such structures.
There is one other one, and that is
shown here. That is to take several
chains, whether they are
linear or branched.
I am just going to draw several
straight chains here.
And it is possible to link chains
by joining them with some covalent
bridges. This is a covalent bridge,
this is a covalent bridge, and it
actually links one chain to another.
And imagine the mechanical
properties of this material.
Otherwise, there would be weak Van
der Waals bonds.
And, if we apply a shear stress,
we can cause the material to
plastically deform.
But these are strong covalent bonds.
What will happen is I can move this
material, shear it up to a point,
but then I would encounter the
resistance of these bonds.
And, as soon as I let go of the
applied force, it springs back.
By cross-linking,
this is a cross-linked architecture,
I impart some elasticity. And this
is, in fact, the structure of rubber.
And we call such polymers
elastomers because they will spring
back to shape.
And what would have to happen here
in order to allow for the
cross-links? We have to be able to
form covalent bonds.
If we are going to form covalent
bonds, we have to break some bonds
that are present in the backbone.
If I have bonds such as this in the
backbone, and then I come up with
this R group that wants to somehow
attach, it is pretty clear that if I
break one of these bonds in order to
make the attachment,
I cut the chain. It is axiomatic
then, if I am going to form
cross-links, I need to find a
position along the backbone that has
a double bond.
Thereby, I can break the double
bond, convert it to a single bond,
link up with the cross-linking
bridge and keep the integrity of the
backbone while forming a new bond to
an adjacent chain.
This is the condition for which we
form elastomers and this is the
basis for rubber.
And I think this next cartoon shows
that - here is polyisoprene.
And you can see there is a double
bond in the backbone.
And by presenting sulfur,
sulfur is capable, as is oxygen,
of forming bridges. We saw in the
silicates, in the borates how the
oxygen forms covalent bonds on
either side, thereby linking
silicate units.
Well, sulfur is below oxygen.
If we believe Mendeleev, it should
have similar properties.
And so sulfur is forming bridging
structures breaking these double
bonds and now linking the one orange
backbone with the adjacent
orange backbone.
Sulfur enables cross-linking.
And this, in fact, is discovered
here in Boston.
It was Nathaniel Hawthorne
**Nathaniel Hayward** who was
working in Roxbury and was trying to
stabilize rubber.
Natural rubber is very sticky,
and so he found that by adding
sulfur he could cause the rubber to
lose its stickiness and thereby
develop a synthetic rubber that had
superior properties.
And then it was Charles Goodyear who
came to Boston,
saw this, took the invention and
licensed it. It was Goodyear who
accidently spilled some of this
cross-linked rubber onto a hot stove.
And the thermal treatment gave a
far superior rubber which gave birth
to vulcanization.
And then from there it is all
history of automobile tires and
whatnot. This is advantageous from
a property standpoint.
But it is very disadvantageous from
the standpoint of recycling.
How could one possibly recycle this
material? Let's compare these two.
Let's compare the case of
polyethylene. Polyethylene consists
of many chains and they will
interpenetrate and entangle.
What are the bonds between these
chains? The bonds between these
chains are Van der Waals.
This is a Van der Waals solid.
These are Van der Waals bonds.
And we know Van der Waals bonds are
operative at low temperatures but
not operative at high temperatures.
If we take polyethylene and heat it,
these bonds will weaken and this
will turn liquid.
And we can reprocess this.
By going to high temperature it can
reprocess because we are only
breaking these weak Van
der Waals bonds.
Now, if we take this cross-linked
polyisoprene, I will show it in this
manner, how are we going to
reprocess this?
If we begin to heat this,
we are going to have to go to an
extremely high temperature because
we have to break covalent bonds.
If we go to a temperature high
enough to break these bonds,
if we go to a temperature high
enough to break the backbone,
we go to thermal destruction of the
entire material.
So such materials cannot be
reprocessed by heating.
These are called thermoset.
And thermoset are very difficult to
process, difficult to recycle.
You might say, well, you don't have
to just do it by thermally
reprocessing. Why don't you use
some kind of a chemistry?
Go in there with chemistry that
will attack these bonds.
These are strong covalent bonds.
What kind of a solvent is going to
be strong enough to
snip those bonds?
It is going to be a very aggressive
solvent. And what are the health
effects of the use of that solvent?
Do you want to bet the company on
the use of that and find out later
that you have class action lawsuits
using such chemicals?
This is the issue when you drive
down the highway and see these
mountains of spent automobile tires,
how to recycle them. This is the
issue. Whereas,
over here, you heat this up and you
can redo it. Such materials are
called thermoplastic.
They can be reprocessed or rendered
plastic by a temperature rise.
They are environmentally much,
much easier to process. Afew more
things here with the polyethylene.
This shows what I was just doing on
the document camera.
This is the partially crystallized
polyethylene and this is what it
looks like in these zones.
You do not have all of the chains
lining up, but if you look at the
atoms on end you will see there is
the C2H4 unit.
And the C2H4 units are lined up.
And, sure enough, what is the basis
unit here? It looks orthorhombic,
as you would expect. The molecule
that has the aspect ratio of 2:1 you
expect is going to come out in one
of the Bravais lattices that also
has some anisotropy associated with
it. And here is some x-ray
diffraction data.
This is the diffraction of a fully
crystalline polymer.
If we took a short length
polyethylene and cooled it very
slowly or took it out of a solvent,
we would end up with something that
is totally crystalline.
And we see we have discrete peaks.
Here it is the same material
amorphous. And,
if it is a little bit painful to
look at this because it is
reminiscent of a question on the
recent test, this is
what the data show.
By looking at this mixed spectrum,
you can get a measure of the extent
of crystallization,
by looking at the relative intensity
of the peaks versus this broad
single peak which is associated with
the first nearest neighbors,
because in ethylene we know that
carbon has hydrogens as its nearest
neighbors and so on.
This works just as well as the free
volume as a measure of the degree of
crystallization. So, we see this.
The last thing I want to touch upon
is the polymer synthesis,
just to put that into a formal
setting. I have already shown you
addition polymerization,
which involves the use of a radical
or catalyst-assisted.
And it is characterized by three
stages where I showed you the
initiation in which we generate the
radical. Then there is the growth
of the polymer until we get to the
length of chain that we want.
Then, finally, the extinguishing of
the reaction called termination.
What is really going on here is in
the initiation stage we
create the radical.
Here the growth is simply the
polymerization.
Polymerize, or if you like
attachment. And then over here is
to quench the radical.
And those are the stages that are
involved. All we are really looking
at here is monomer attachment.
And, in this case,
the composition of the polymer is
equal to the composition of the mer
unit. The composition of the
polymer is simply identical to the
composition of the mer unit.
We simply use the radical to
catalyze, and that is
the only effect.
But there is one other way to form,
and this is called a condensation
polymerization.
And it works a little bit
differently. It involves more than
one mer type. I am going to show
this as mer type number one,
which has associated with it a
terminal hydrogen.
And mer number two that has
associated with it a terminal
hydroxyl. And condensation
polymerization works to attach the
hydroxyl to the terminal hydrogen to
form a covalent bond between the
residual R1 and R2 and expels water
vapor. These reactions are
conducted at temperatures above 100
degrees C. This is expelled.
And ultimately is captured as a
condensate. Oddly enough,
condensation polymerization,
which involves the stepwise building
of the polymer by reaction between
two different mer types and
expulsion of water vapor condensate
is named not for what it is but for
the byproduct that is not part of it.
This is the prototypical reaction.
Clearly here you keep losing water.
In this case, the composition
differs and the final mass of
polymer is not equal to the
composition of the mer groups.
And the mass is less than the sum
of the masses of all of the mer
groups because we keep losing water.
I think here we have some examples
of the various materials.
This, again, is taken from your
reading. Here is a suite of
addition polymers,
many of these you encounter in
everyday life.
I have been talking about
polyethylene. If we replace the
hydrogens with fluorines,
we get PTFE which you know by the
trade name Teflon.
Polypropylene. Polystyrene which
you have seen in these clamshells.
Not so much today in coffee cups for
their insulating capability.
Polyacrylonitrile is a fabric Orlon.
PVC is that white tubing that you
see used in plumbing facilities.
Polymethylmethacrylate, many of you
are wearing eyeglasses that are made
of this material.
This is Plexiglas or Lucite.
And so on. And down here even some
of the rubbers.
On the other hand,
here are the condensation polymers.
And notably are the nylons, which
are made by condensation
polymerization.
And I have put a little bit of fine
structure on here.
You can look at this on the website.
The bond that will link the R1 to
R2 is called the amide bond.
This is the amide bond. And so
nylons are known generically
as polyamides.
And, furthermore,
there is on end that has the
carboxylic acid end,
and then the other end which has the
amino end. And,
as you go down, you see Kevlar is
here, which you know is used as a
substitute for steel belting in
tires, also used as the fiber in
bulletproof vests.
Some fabrics here,
Dacron and Mylar, various polyesters.
The polycarbonates.
This rigid phenyl group here is
what gives the polycarbonates
their high strength.
This is Lexan which is used in jet
engine windshields and is also used
in sports goggles to give you the
resistance against impact and so on.
These are made by this process, and
we are going to see this process
again when we talk about protein
synthesis because Mother Nature
works by condensation polymerization.
There are many similarities between
the nylons and the proteins that
make up our bodies.
What I would like to do in the last
five minutes is talk about an
example of the use of block
copolymers in energy.
And some research that has been
going on here at MIT for about ten
years now looking at new materials
to make superior batteries,
batteries for the wireless age.
And these are the kinds of
batteries that exist today in terms
of the amount of energy
they store per charge.
And you see lead acid,
which is abundant and cheap,
is actually quite low in terms of
how much energy it stores.
And what is in your cell phone and
your laptop is the lithium ion
battery which is 150 watt hours per
kilogram by this metric.
And, in fact, it was the advent of
the nickel metal hydride battery
that enabled the laptop computer.
All of the components were in place
in the 1980s, but sodium sulfur is a
molten salt batter.
It operates at 300 degrees C so that
was not very popular for laptop use.
The only thing that was available
was down here NiCd.
And people were not going to
release laptops that had a runtime
of about one hour.
But with the advent of nickel metal
hydride it all of a sudden became
sensible to put out such devices.
And now we have a lithium ion. And,
ironically, as the capacity of the
battery has risen,
the appliances that go on the laptop
have risen.
And so the runtime does not change
because each next generation has a
more intense power hog of a CPU.
You want a DVD, you want a fancy
screen and so on.
All of that is consuming energy.
But if you knew how to power it
down and run it minimally,
you would find that you could get
run times of six,
seven hours. The approach that we
used here was to use block
copolymers. And we used block
copolymers such that we
wanted to get a solid.
You see, people think of batteries
as these cylindrical devices that
are very heavy,
but we had a different image.
We thought that this should be the
battery. The battery should remind
us of something like this,
and this is called dreaming.
This is a potato chip bag. You
think it is just nothing by a lowly
potato chip bag.
Open it up sometime.
What do you find? You see it is a
multilayer laminate of polymer and
metal, because the potato chip is
precious. You have to protect it
against spoilage.
It can spoil by becoming soggy from
humidity or it can become rancid
from oxidation.
You need the polymer to protect it
from one and the metal to protect it
from the other.
But this tells me that you can make
a multilayer thin film laminate very
cheaply. If this polymer could be
made into a lithium ion conductor,
we would have a solid state battery.
Instead of aluminum, we would put
lithium. Instead of this polymer,
we would put something that could
conduct lithium ions.
And then we would put the cathode
on here. Now we have something that
is solid state. It is very light.
And it has a property that no other
battery has. You can reshape it.
You can wear it. You can put it in
the body of a car.
You could change the watch band to
change the battery.
If you can think conceptually,
you can do different things. That
is how it began.
And with my colleague Professor
Anne Mayes who started a program to
look at a class of materials,
block copolymers that were chosen in
such a way to give lithium ion
conduction at room temperature.
Solids are very poor ionic
conductors. Most solids that you
know that conduct ions only operate
at high temperatures.
The oxygen sensor in your car does
not work for about the first 15
minutes. When the car is cold,
the oxygen sensor is getting garbage
for a signal. It has to heat up.
But we don't want a battery that
runs at 300 degrees C.
At least I don't. There are
selection rules here
that went into play.
And, ultimately,
we built something that looked like
this, that has a methacrylate
backbone and different side groups
that could solvate lithium ions,
and we made the materials and
ultimately made first generation
batteries that are thin film,
mechanically flexible. And the
choice of electrode materials
provided its lithium-based chemistry
and so on allow us to go forward.
And it was by using the principles
shown here on these boards that we
were able to engineer a polymer that
could have the mechanical properties
of something like Saran wrap but
have the electrical properties of
sulfuric acid in your lead acid
battery. That was the paradox,
how to engineer those seemingly
irreconcilable properties.
Right there, control of local
structure. And I have all this
stuff up here that we don't have
time to go through,
but let me show you where you can go
when you get something
that is really nice.
Look at this. This is flexible
solar cell. This is silicon on a
polymer substrate,
so it is collecting photons and
converting them into electrons.
And then you take something like
this and put it on the back of a
flexible solar cell.
And then you put on the front of
this the LEDs.
You put this up in the roof,
you collect the photons, and then
afterwards you get the photons back.
Now that is change.
Learn your chemistry.
Have a nice weekend.